I got the player Thomas maybe like three
hours of atomic heart this is the new
game from the new developer coming out
of Russia monkfish
um it at first glance everybody look at
it and be like that's Bioshock and it is
it wears his influences on his sleeve
for sure um it's definitely Bioshock at
a look right when you start playing a
little bit more you realize it's
Bioshock it's Wolfenstein it's new
Wolfenstein it's Arcane games a little
bit right it's a little bit a little bit
of immersive Sim stealth stuff going on
um and I think as a first effort this is
really impressive to me again I'm only a
couple hours in but it's super
impressive to me so uh like General
overview
um so the game is essentially about uh
alternate history sort of Russia 1940s
1950s where uh basically Russia uh you
know scientists a specific scientist in
Russia has come up with something that
they call like a polymer right